I love farmer's market yeah did I say
that yeah I don't remember I said that
you say that like every day when you
wake up in the morning honey did I
remind you I love farmers markets yeah
it's a real breaker so we got kicked out
oh my God Tebow you're on top of
Tristana
that's not nice Teemo
[Music]
okay this is our first vlog
in Arizona Phoenix we've been here for a
week many times yeah a week not two
weeks we've been there for one week yeah
should we put the hood down should we
put the roof no no no no not yet no no
it's kind of cool wait a second this is
our first Vlog here we're gonna take
your lunch with us I don't know you
planned the whole thing Saturday it's
our fun day we're doing Dog Festival
we're doing Farmers Market we're doing
new coffee shop we're doing Botanical
Gardens and street street stores
something yeah and then maybe some salsa
dancing some dinner salsa dancing are we
going salsa dancing Maybe
we'll see where the day takes us and you
get to join us let's go timo's ready are
you ready Timo you ready to go ready to
have this fun day with us together so
that you guys are not alone
at the Airbnb
all right we're here first stop what is
it Evan
why are we going to farmer's market you
know those farmers markets I love
farmer's market yeah did I say that yeah
I don't remember I said that I say that
like every day when you wake up in the
morning heavy did I remind you I love
farmers markets
[Music]
Evan got a peanut chocolate and he's
gonna taste it right now
delicious
flaky very what
flaky like his mouth it's good good
[Music]
that was fun look at how much stuff I'm
carrying
I got a lot of stuff Evan was just sweet
I'll take the dogs you carry this big
thing okay but how do we switch too yeah
I love you so it's a lot of stuff to
carry okay but then we got some
vegetables and we got some empanadas
hello
vlogging each other
okay you ready let's stop okay let's go
let's eat our Empanada first
pricey for five dollars yeah
well
oh Curry that's a vegan one vegan curry
is it good oh good okay here you can try
the other one
oh no coconutty
okay
hmm yeah yeah good A little bit of spice
not too much see the beef
all right oh
better yep no I mean yeah good good
we're at the five bucks let's go
enjoying the roof down
wet sunny weather
the January
freezing cold snow storms in Toronto
okay this is Jeff
okay where are we going next Evan uh
street street festival shops okay
have some kind
where are we Evan
The Churchill what's a Churchill a
Japanese come and sell their stuff okay
so we're gonna see if we're gonna buy
anything Nina likes this stuff getting
out seeing entrepreneurs
and uh being in the sun with her family
let's go
[Music]
House of Churchill pretty good yeah we
didn't get anything did we get anything
no no eating anything yeah well it's
always good to see what entrepreneurs
are selling nothing really hit our style
that's okay
next stop we're gonna go get some coffee
at a little Artisan Marketplace and then
there's a dog
Festival something that we're gonna go
check out
let's go
[Music]
we've arrived at Monsoon Market we don't
know whether they accept dogs or not but
we will find out yeah it's a real
breaker Evan is going to get a coffee
specialty latte yeah that's strawberry
strawberry latte something like that
okay let's go see yeah
[Music]
we didn't get anything from this door it
was an interesting store they love dogs
Teemo interesting I got some treats
they were enjoying it right Timothy you
guys on treat
yeah uh they didn't have the coffee
because the guy were only there in the
morning so Evan's kind of sad that was
fine yeah yeah I got another place we're
gonna go to Lux Central so the coffee
place they're they're pretty legendary
but they they sit in this parking lot in
a bus
but they leave after the morning because
that's when the rush is done so we went
to the farmer's market instead of here
which is fine so now we're gonna go to
Lux coffee five minute drive
and get some Luxe drinks for my Lux wife
and myself let's go
[Music]
but we don't see anything
it's a shoe store that's a shoe store
yeah maybe this is
or or what about the other one
[Music]
okay what did you get Evan we got the
same thing no no we gotta uh they
recommended it vanilla cinnamon
latte Nina got oat milk and I got
regular this is what they're known for
highly recommended from the Barista so
cheers here we go
it's different
not very strong this is the latte oh I
just got I just got a shot of cinnamon
or something
I also got you something too
oh it's like uh
look at that
I don't know what this is
[Music]
oh Nutella yep oh
unlike shortbread okay you like it
Nina's the best we love Ninja
okay next up we're going to uh doggies
Festival doggy Street Festival they were
sleeping when uh just before we got here
and then Timo woke up as he heard the
dog dog barking yeah right Timo you
heard something
you ready to go Tima you went to Santa
heard that
[Music]
okay we arrived Evan a lot of dogs yep
our dogs she's scared
she's afraid of all dogs
she must sometimes like other dogs but
sometimes you're scared
okay we're gonna explore
do you have fun Evan yeah it was good
yeah lots of dogs lots of big dogs yeah
huge bigger dogs than in Toronto yeah
Toronto is a lot of small spaces so
people have small dogs here you got we
had four Great Danes all together from
four different people yeah Great Dane
little secret that's the Marmaduke dog
if you guys know the cartoon we never
see Great Danes in Toronto
anyway yeah it was good the dogs are
exhausted
and it's finally starting to get hot
this is the first day where it's like
hot hot here I like it Nina's hot hot
too
[Music]
we have arrived in the cactus Botanical
Garden they have a special things that
they do once a month something like that
once a month for doggies so and it's a
Saturday today and then they allow dogs
so here we are taking the two doggies
where is she oh my God Tebow you're on
top of Tristana
that's not nice Timo
[Music]
so we got kicked out because the last
admission for dogs is at 10 30.
they only allow dogs from 9 to 11 30.
it's not a doggy day it's doggy morning
and it is 2 30. so I didn't know that we
had to be here before 10 30. but uh it's
okay it's the best
we relax a little bit I made some yummy
tuna healthy snacks you you relax that
was working yeah okay I relaxed well I
was so hungry when I was when it was
great did you filmed the wraps no I did
not oh my gosh that was so good it was
the fresh lettuce that we just bought
yeah organic Fresh Farm picked lettuce
with and then you put like tuna and some
onion and there what'd you put in there
it's like a vegan keto it was so good it
was so good Nina's like I have a snack
for you it's like okay I was working
outside but you got to come inside to
eat it because it's kind of messy like
okay
yeah we're gonna go for a walk with the
dogs we'll find the water let's go
because it's time for them to go outside
again register now yeah
[Music]
all right we had to go walk
okay we're gonna go to dinner grab some
dinner go to dinner grab some dinner
Nina wanted Pho yeah because Pho is it's
still gluten free because rice noodle
it's rice and they have I guess meat and
stuff wait rice has Gluten no no rice
noodles doesn't have gluten really the
gluten rice has Gluten there are two
different rice perfect yeah I don't know
what I'm talking about
yeah rice noodle doesn't have gluten in
there great yeah anyways let's go Nina
one smoke yeah happy
[Music]
all right we have arrived it doesn't
seem that busy for Saturday
[Music]
are we making a good choice Evan
Nina picked it so therefore it's a good
choice even if we vomit from the food
it's a good choice
[Music]
foreign
we just finished our dinner yep the soup
is actually pretty good was very hot and
tasty when they brought out hot and
tasty yeah that's like Nina
hot tasting how did you enjoy your meal
that's okay well that's too bad I know
but Pho is a Vietnamese food I have it's
always just okay for me it's like it's
never great and it's never bad it's just
okay Chinese was never good for you too
it depends Chinese food has more flavors
flavors in it like I I I don't I don't
eat pho
so then I always end up with like some
kind of rice dish and it's just rice
with meat and the sauce it's like it
tastes the same pretty much everywhere
it's a simple dish so it's hard to mess
up
uh but it's also hard to make it like
amazing so but need is happy and that's
what matters okay hot and tasty let's go
I did not even press record
that's amazing did you press it now just
yeah we ended the video it was it was
fantastic and then I realized I didn't
press record so here we are again
we're just saying Evan's gonna plan
another thing for next week that would
be totally a surprise wow no pressure
yeah if you want to see our last
adventure check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and we'll see you
there